from a secret hot invisible man to
monstrous adult jokes hotel transylvania
4 is packed with hilarious references
and easter eggs you might have missed
yapikai movie lovers i'm jan and in this
video i'm revealing 27 deliciously dark
details and hidden gags of filmmakers
stuck into the movie some spoilers ahead
of course so take care
the movie begins with the hotel's 125th
anniversary party and a spectacular
array of monster performances organized
by johnny including the werewolf kids
running out on stage with a set of cards
that spell out happy anniversary but in
their mad rush the pups trip and tumble
over each other and as they get up their
cards now read very fine
the scene quickly moves on but although
it looks like the name phineas there's a
crucial gap so that that p h i n e is
pronounced fine and that last s card was
going to complete the end of another
word you can see the joke in full for
just the tiniest fraction of a second
later when drak freezes the chaos at the
party before he quickly rearranges the
letters to read happy anniversary there
are some devilishly dark and gruesome
little details you might have easily
overlooked at the party dinner tables
there's a centerpiece that's not only
made up of flowers but also tentacles
and eyeballs instead of ordinary forks
and knives the guests have mini axes and
prongs to eat with and then there's a
salt and pepper pots whose design
appears to be inspired by the infamous
iron maiden torture devices given the
little spikes on top and the anguished
faces
when van helsing takes johnny down into
his lab to show him the monster vacation
ray you can spot a ton of weird and
wonderful objects from the former
villain's monster hunting days including
a huge dinosaur skeleton a mysterious
humanoid skeleton with horns a giant
robot outfit and an old diving suit he
might have used to discover the ancient
underwater civilization of atlantis and
hanging from the ceiling is a replica of
the aeroplane he used when hunting drake
in hotel transylvania 3. also there
appears to be the body of a giant shark
which could be what happened to sharky
one of the monster pets drak introduced
to tinkles in the short film monster
pets
when van helsing uses the
monstrification ray on gigi the gerbil
and then on johnny right next to him is
a giant circular stone with an engraving
of a tentacled monster a secret
reference to the kraken that van helsing
hypnotized and used to attack drak and
the other monsters in hotel transylvania
3. and just like he converted the
friendly kraken into an angry beast with
the instrument of destruction in that
movie in hotel transylvania 4 van
helsing's contraption also slowly turns
johnny into a raging uncontrollable
monster and the central part of the
stone with the face and surrounding wave
pattern is the secret entrance to the
runes of atlantis from the third film
it's probably no coincidence either that
there's a portrait of one of van
helsing's ancestors from the third movie
just outside the elevator door at the
hotel looking on as drak accidentally
turns himself into a human with the
monster vacation ray
drak tries to hide his transformation
from mavis and the other monsters help
by distracting her with wayne's new
dance moves the routine he tries to do
is inspired by real-life social media
dance challenges in particular the viral
hit renegade dance created by jalayla
harmon
and speaking of social media stars the
character of party monsters played by
streamer ninja aka tyler blevins oh yeah
when griffin becomes human the drak pack
is shocked to learn that he's been naked
from the moment we first met him a
little hat tip to the fans of the
franchise who guessed this early on have
you seriously been naked this whole time
uh yeah why would only my glasses be
visible notice how he also has red curly
hair as he explained in the first movie
what's wrong with red curly hair why are
you getting upset i have read curly hair
now griffin's real human form as a
balding pot-bellied middle-aged man
caused a bit of a stir among some hotel
transylvania fans when the movie's
trailer came out over 30 000 people
signed a petition on behalf of the
invisible man simps community asking
sony animation to make griffin hot and
it's possible the filmmakers give a
little nod to this because they actually
snuck an alternate version of griffin
into the final movie to catch this watch
really carefully during the crystal cave
scene because as broken reflections of
each character appear in the giant
crystals when griffin wanders into view
in the corner there's a design of him
that looks completely different
including a full head of hair don't be
so uptight i'm in viz man just because
you're invisible doesn't mean you get to
be naked gremlin air makes a hilarious
return for the fourth movie and there's
a bit of humorous lamp shading that
acknowledges how ridiculous it is that
the plane can actually fly how is this
plane even in the sky is that duct tape
holding the wing together
after arriving in south america johnny
and drak take a bus to the amazon but
when johnny's monster size slows it down
he decides to move the vehicle along by
picking it up and running with it a
shout out to the old school animation
the flintstones where fred and his
friend barney would sometimes use foot
power to literally run their car
there's a long-running joke in the
franchise that drak supposedly goes
round saying blah blah blah yes fellow
dracula there's only one way blah blah
blah i do not say blah blah blah blah
blah blah i don't know where that comes
from and it's true that according to
vampires.com dracula has never said the
phrase either in the books or the
live-action movies that came before the
animated movie franchise however in
hotel transylvania 4 as drak tries to
explain why he made up the monster real
estate law he says johnny found out that
i was giving you guys the hotel but then
he had a johnny takeover escalator's
name changes blablabla although erica
gave up her monster hunting ways at the
end of the third movie when she goes in
search of drak and johnny she gets some
of her old monster hunting contraptions
out again there's her blimp which is
full of lethal weapons
okay yeah it's a death trap and the
tank-like armored vehicle she drives has
a license plate that reads monster
hunter the jeep also has a v-shaped
ornament as a nod to her family name
just like the car her great granddaddy
chased track with when the gang
eventually arrive at the crystal cave
they enter through an opening that looks
like the jaws of a monster and when the
cave begins to collapse later on as
frank and eunice run from the falling
rocks they both say if he ruins my hair
i'm never gonna forgive her that's a
funny call back to the third movie where
eunice was playing volleyball and was
worried about getting her hair wet
everybody just please watch the hair
watch the hair and the way the gang
shield mavis from the sun's rays at the
end of the movie as she runs to reach
johnny and turn him back into a human is
a neat parallel to how drak was shielded
from the sun as he raced to reach johnny
at the end of the first movie don't
worry
we got you covered the way the wolf pups
extend in a line to provide shade for
mavis is similar to how the townspeople
formed a line to cover drak in the
original film
and something you might not have noticed
is that the voice of drak changed for
this fourth film from adam sandler who
played him in the first three movies to
voice actor impressionist and youtuber
brian hull hull already voiced drak in
the short film monster pets and does an
excellent job in the new feature
sounding uncannily like sandler's drag
thank you johnny how wonderful so what
did you think of the fourth and final
hotel transylvania movie and how it
ended and who are your favorite
characters leave your thoughts in the
comments below if you enjoyed this video
then do hit the like button i really
appreciate it and tap left if you'd like
to discover all the easter eggs and
everything you missed in disney's
encounter and more animated movies
thanks for watching and see you next
time yippee kai movie lovers